The Punisher has been a mainstay of
Marvel movies and television for decades
but there's one project fans never got
to see Kurt shutters take on the
Punisher - which was scrapped in favor
of Punisher war zone which hit theaters
in 2008 sutter of course has since
become famous as to create an executive
producer of sons of anarchy so we asked
him for an exclusive look back at what
he had planned here's Kurt Sutter on The
Punisher movie we never got to see not
Marvel enough for Marvel Sutter was
hired to do a simple polish of The
Punisher - screenplay
but he had his own ideas of how the
story should go he decided he was going
to quote mix it up and make it different
Marvel honcho Kevin Feige didn't
appreciate his tinkering with their
characters as Sutter told us they're
2-dimensional for a reason that's the
purpose they serve so I was trying to
expand the Marvel Universe in a
direction it should not have been
expanded in less guns more introspection
so why did Sutter's vision fail he
explained it was because he wanted it to
be more about character and less about
formulaic action saying I was trying to
write to the emotionality of this dude
and motivate the absurd violence with
some kind of meaning his efforts
included writing in a love interest in
order to as he put it explore the pain
through that relationship who punishes
you
but Sutter's efforts were at
cross-purposes with Marvel's vision for
the film Sutter said quote there's only
X amount of time in the movies so you
have moments of that but you can't
really have a subplot that explores that
kind of thing not in a summer
blockbuster or a Marvel picture
Kevin Feige was not amused
after Sutter turned in his radically
different script he had the
uncomfortable experience of going over
it with producer Gale Anne Hurd and
Kevin Feige said her told us quote I
think they realized what I was trying to
do and how wrong it was so they tried to
guide me back and like I said I did
another pass but poor Gale Anne Hurd we
were sitting at a big table and I think
she started glancing over at Kevin going
I don't know what happened shortly after
Sutter was fired and at the end of it
the punisher will be died better on TV
the only piece of Sutter script to make
it into the final version of punisher
warzone was the origin of the bad guy
jigsaw the film was a failure but the
characters returned in 2016 on the
second season of daredevil was popular
enough to earn Punisher his own Netflix
series starring Jon Bernthal so why was
punisher more successful on television
than film Soto thinks the character is
just better suited to the small screen
telling us that quote as powerful a
character as Frank Castle is there's a
real linear component to that narrative
and it almost works better tangentially
alongside of another story rather than
standing up on its own that's what you
were able to do with TV you can go
sideways you just can't go sideways in a
feature not unless it's an indie but in
terms of Hollywood the narrative has to
be moving forward thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which version of Punisher is your
favorite
[Music]